partir surfer en iran quelle idée bon
c'est pas la mienne c'est celle d'un ami
stuart qui voyagent et qui servent
beaucoup et il savait que personne
encore n'avait jamais surfé en iran et
il savait aussi qu'il y avait
potentiellement des vagues dans le sud
est du pays dans une région qui
s'appelle le baloutchistan qui est la
région qui est en rouge sur la carte de
sécurité diplomatique
une région qui s'étend sur trois pays
qui sont l'iran l'afghanistan et le
pakistan considérée comme une des plus
dangereuses au monde
et comme on peut le voir qui est
formellement déconseillée par ministère
des affaires étrangères et bien sûr voir
tu m'appelles me dit ça te dit d'aller
surfer au balouchistan alors évidemment
au début j'ai pensé que c'était
peut-être dangereux d'aller surfer au
baloutchistan et en même temps ce moment
là j'étais en train de me lancer dans la
vidéo est d'essayer de réaliser mon rêve
de devenir réalisatrice
alors que rien mais d dessinée moi j'ai
étudié en sciences physiques
rien à voir alors quand j'ai réfléchi à
la proposition je me suis dit que
c'était peut-être l'opportunité de
ramener des images uniques une
expérience insolite l'opportunité
d'aller visiter un pays qui m'a toujours
fasciné et aussi l'opportunité de ne
surtout pas donner raison à ceux qui
essayent de nous faire croire que l'on
doit avoir peur du coup j'ai accepté et
stewart a tout organisé
il m'a mis en contact avec une surfeuse
l'irlandaise skis on devait partir tous
les trois il a tout prévu sauf qu'il a
raté son avion où il s'est dégonflé je
ne sais pas du coup avec cette serveuse
skis on s'est rencontré pour la première
fois à terrain avec nos planches de surf
et moi et de ma petite caméra et là on
s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on fait bach ce
qu'on fait évidemment on avait notre
curiosité
nos appréhensions aussi par rapport à
l'iran un petit peu d'ignorance par
rapport à la région d'aller se rendre
mais on était animée quand même toutes
les deux par un goût de l'aventuré alors
on s'est dit bon maintenant qu'on est là
on y va on est partis tous les deux
veulent schiste ans en arrivant sur
place ont été heureusement surprise
d'une part parce qu'on a pu surfer sans
problème
et d'autre part parce que les locaux
étaient très contents de voir du surf
pour la première fois sur leurs côtes
alors un premier voyage inoubliable un
premier voyage trop court et au fond de
moi une intuition qui me dit que c'est
seulement le début de quelque chose de
plus grand parce que je sais pas
pourquoi mais depuis que je suis arrivé
en iran je me sens bien il ya quelque
chose dans ce pays qui m'attire
est ce que c'est le décalage entre ce
que j'imaginais est ce que je trouve du
coup ces décalages m'interpelle et j'ai
envie d'en savoir plus alors en partant
je sais déjà au fond qu'un jour je
reviendrai
j'ai fait un petit film de ce premier
voyage qui a été vue un million de fois
sur internet
derrière j'ai eu des retours d'iraniens
d'iraniennes qui voulait savoir si on
pensait revenir à l'art en 2013 on a
décidé de repartir mais cette fois avec
des planches pour partager et moi j'ai
voulu allier mes deux passions pour le
cinéma et pour le sport et faire cette
fois ci un long métrage de cette
nouvelle odyssée faire un film c'est
difficile faire un film de surf féminin
en iran c'est un peu plus compliqué tout
a été difficile difficile de trouver une
production qui veulent financer un
tournage très incertain surtout qu'à ce
moment là j'étais complètement anonyme
dans l'industrie personne ne me
connaissait
difficile d'avoir des visas et d
obtention de filmer en iran difficile
d'envoyer des planches dans un pays sous
sanction difficile de trouver un
caméraman que je voulais absolument
iraniens parce que lui aurait les codes
que moi je n'avais pas et puis avec
toute cette logistique difficile d'avoir
le cerveau disponible pour écrire mon
histoire à écrire un film parce que j
allais quand même pour ça alors quand
j'ai imaginé ce scénario j'ai imaginé qu
en fédérant un groupe de femmes autour
du surf ce serait plus facile
d'encourager d'autres femmes à se jeter
à l'eau alors j'ai fait des recherches
sur facebook et j'ai trouvé deux
sportifs iranienne déjà très engagé dans
leur discipline menacé rajhi qui est
professeur de snowboard qui a été la
première iranienne enseigner le
snowboard dans les montagnes téhéranaise
et shalaya cynique a été une des
premières femmes iraniennes à faire la
plongée sous marine
je leur ai écrit pour savoir s'il
voulait se joindre à nous et après on a
surfé elles ont dit oui sans hésiter
donc c'est comme ça que mon film devait
commencer on devait partir toutes les
quatre au baloutchistan
toute cette préparation m'a pris plus de
8 mois c'était compliqué bien le dire
surtout je me suis senti seul même si
mes parents m'ont toujours beaucoup
soutenue dans toutes mes aventures mais
j'avais l'impression de porter tout
projet sur mes épaules et au plus au fur
et à mesure que j'avançais dans le
projet au fur à mesure j'arrivais face à
des murs et puis j'arrive et face à ces
murs que j'avais des doutes évidemment
et des doutes sur ma capacité même à
pouvoir faire un film alors que je
n'avais jamais étudié le cinéma et dans
ces cas là ils sont rares les gens qui
vous pousse à suivre vos rêves sont très
rares au contraire on vous dit qu'il
faut assurer ses arrières il faut faire
attention qu'il faut suivre le chemin il
ya beaucoup de personnes surtout dans un
milieu de l'audiovisuel qui ont essayé
de me convaincre d'arrêter de m'obstiner
à vouloir faire ce film qui de toute
façon ne rentrera pas dans les cases
ok alors comme au fond j'avais une
intuition qui ne faisait qu il fallait
que j'aille jusqu'au bout et que je sais
aussi qu'une opportunité comme celle ci
ne se reproduirait plus j'ai décidé
d'ignorer leurs conseils et j'ai
continué à taper dans les murs alors
j'ai bien fait le 22 août 2013 j'en suis
encore j'ai eu mon visa pour l'iran
j'ai eu un mardi soir j'ai décollé
mercredi matin j'étais prête un j'arrive
à téhéran à 6 heures épuisé nerveusement
à bout à cette heure on m'apprend que je
n'aurai qu'une semaine de visas au lieu
de 6 pour faire un film d'une heure ses
courses est trop court à 8 heures la
petite boîte de production qui avaient
accepté de me financer au dernier moment
décide que c'est trop court et préfère
me planter à 9 heures les autorités
m'appelle pour me dire que mon caméraman
n'est pas autorisé à venir filmer au
baloutchistan à 10h les autorités me
rappelle pour me dire que mes planches
sont bloqués à la douane et à 11h
j'appelle ma mère et je pleure
c'est un cauchemar y'a rien qui se passe
comme prévu un qui se passe d'ailleurs
et là je me dis mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait ces huit derniers mois c'est pas
possible qu'est ce que je fais de ma vie
quoi hélas une fois de plus je me suis
dit mais enfin bon quand même j'ai une
semaine de visas c'est mieux que rien
j'ai tellement galéré pour la voir
j'ai ma caméra je pose potentiellement
film et moi même et puis ce qui est
moindre année chacune une planche donc
on peut faire ça refait les filles alors
comme la première fois on se dit voilà
maintenant qu'on est là on y va donc on
est reparti les 4 ou baloutchistan et en
arrivant sur place
j'ai compris qu'ils ne nous arrivera
rien parce qu'on a été invité à
rencontrer le membre du parlement de la
région et les hommes les plus influents
de la région
donc ils nous ont invités pour savoir
qui on était éventuellement ce qu'on ait
faire alors trois heures de thé plus
tard un bon repas beaucoup de pantomime
et on est repartis rassurés rassuré
parce qu'ils ont une garantie qu'ils
allaient assurer notre protection et
monsieur jack galles qui est l'homme qui
porte la planche
moi aussi assuré qu'il ferait en sorte
que je puisse filmer dans de bonnes
conditions
et là contre toute attente hull en
maille solutionner tous mes problèmes
le problème de visa mais problème de
planches mon caméraman m'appelait pour
que pour me dire qu'un de ses amis était
sur la route pour venir ce film à sa
place donc tout s'arrangeait alors on a
continué on a continué on a trouvé une
petite plage de 20 villages de pêcheurs
qui s'appellera mines et c'est là qu'on
a décidé de se jeter à l'eau pour la
première fois alors c'était un moment
émouvant parce qu'on ne savait pas
comment les locaux allaient réagir en
voyant des iraniennes dans l'eau il
avait déjà vue des européennes n'est pas
encore dire aliens on a vite été
entourée par des hommes par des garçons
parmi eux il y avait un jeune baloutche
qui s'appelle chams qui est très très
vite devenu un rôle modèle pour les
enfants ainsi très vite devenu un des
meilleurs amis alors ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'un petit garçon qui nous allons
décide lui aussi là mais doit d'en faire
parce que comme on était que des femmes
dans l'eau il a cru que c'est un sport
de femmes
et comme on est très cool on a dit ok
du coup on a surfé ensemble en
respectant les consignes de la veille
les hommes d'un côté les femmes de
l'autre
sauf que la vague nous a tous réunis au
même endroit c'est toute la magie est la
beauté de ce sport ce qui fait tomber
toutes les barrières dans l'océan on
s'oublie et ça fait du bien de s'oublier
la religion le genre la culture l'océan
il s'en fout du cou ou disons qu'on a
brisé une règle sans le vouloir et
naturellement la pratique du surf est
devenu mixte
alors on a surfé ensemble pendant une
semaine on a eu des maris qui nous ont
demandé de faire surfer leurs femmes des
papas qui nous ont demandé de faire ça
fait leur fille et c'est à ce moment là
que j'ai compris j'ai compris pourquoi
j'avais fait tout ça pourquoi je m'étais
donné autant mal pourquoi j'avais rien
lâcher c'était pour vivre ce moment là
ce moment de partage dans un océan qui
ne fait pas de détails
tout ça c'est en images
mon film est terminé j'ai réussi à le
finir j'ai organisé des plates formes
fin des collectes sur des plateformes de
croo founding pour financer la
postproduction et puis j'ai réussi à
négocier avec des amis pour qu'ils
travaillent avec contre une bonne
bouteille de vin ça marche encore mon
fils a bel into de 6 depuis 2014 il a
fait le tour du monde
d'ailleurs il a été projeté dans des
avions de grandes compagnies aériennes
et puis il a été diffusée dans de
nombreux festivals internationaux dont
téhéran et san diego en californie alors
c'est très symbolique mais pour moi
c'est très important d'imaginer qu'il
ait suffisamment objectif pourrait
diffuser partout et s'il est objectif
c'est parce que je les réaliser avec une
équipe de grands cinéastes iraniens j'ai
la chance de travailler avec eux et que
ensemble on a pu confronter nos points
de vue pour parler d'un pays dont je
n'avais ni les codes ni la complexité
moi qui pensais que ce film était un
gouffre financier en fait si nalement
professionnellement il m'a ouvert
beaucoup de portes
maintenant les producteurs m'appelle
pour travailler avec moi et l'année
dernière j'ai gagné un award pour le
meilleur documentaire sport et paix
alors en réalisant et en faisant ce film
j'avais
j'ai réalisé un de mes rêves qui était
devenue réalisatrice mais j'en avais un
autre de rêve c'était de continuer à
écrire cette histoire avec mes amis
iraniens parce que l'arrivée du surf
avait généré beaucoup d' enthousiasme
alors depuis 2003 je suis reparti de 9
ans en iran et avec mes amis mona xala
chams
habib azizi ses frères tous les
pionniers de l'aventuré on a créé un
groupe pour se fédérer pour continuer à
développer le surf et pour essayer de le
rendre accessible au plus grand nombre
en a plein de projets ensemble
le prochain c'est de construire une
école de surf sera pas géré amin
d'ailleurs c'est en construction d'avoir
une fédération de surf iranienne de
d'organiser du nettoyage de plage aussi
et puis un projet qui moi me tient à
coeur qui est de permettre aux femmes de
surfer dans de bonnes conditions parce
que je n'en ai pas parlé mais en iran on
doit surfer couverte c'est la loi et
pour l'instant les tenues sont pas
adaptés on a des cagoules en lycra qui
glisse détenus qui sont lourdes alors
avec mes amis et ran yen on a décidé de
travailler sur sur une tenue avec des
stylistes
on essaye de confectionner une tenue qui
sera sécurisé confortable pratique et
féminines c'est important et je suis
convaincu que d'avoir des tenues
adaptées de permettre aux femmes de
faire du sport dans de bonnes conditions
c'est leur permet de s'émanciper aussi
parce qu'on sait à quel point le sport
est un outil d'émancipation
le dernier rêvant en organise pardon des
événements réguliers à leurs derniers
événements on était
une cinquantaine il ya eu des iraniens
qui sont venus des quatres qu'un des
quatre coins du pays pour essayer le
surf des hommes des femmes elles sont
plus en plus nombreuses
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux c'est
super ce qui me touche c'est quand je
vois aussi le niveau de mes amis par
exemple
mona qui a été la première iranienne a
surfé dans son pays championne de
snowboard future championne de surf
je souhaite ou encore chams qui a été le
premier arrivé sur la plage qui est
maintenant professeur de surf c'est lui
qui enseignent nouveaux arrivants alors
si professionnellement cette histoire
m'a ouvert beaucoup de portes c'est
surtout personnellement qu'elle m'a
enrichi j'ai découvert une culture
je me suis fait des amis j'ai vécu des
moments inoubliables j ai rencontré mon
meilleur ami chams alors chams
il est baloutche musulmans sunnites
il a grandi dans un petit village ira
iraniens à la frontière pakistanaise son
père à quatre femmes
il a 15 frères et soeurs moi je suis
française ate et laïque
j'ai grandi dans un petit village
bressan à la frontière suisse a priori
mon père n'a qu'une femme
j'ai un frère chams et moi on a des
cultures très différentes pourtant on
est amis c'est clair on ne parle pas la
même langue on est devenus confident des
mimes des dessins beaucoup d'auto
d'autodérision c'est important et
surtout on a une croyance commune on
croit tous les deux très très fort en
cette belle histoire sportif que l'on
était en train d'écrire ensemble celle
d'un nouveau sport en iran de celle du
surf
c'est une coïncidence mais j'étais au
baloutchistan la semaine dernière je
viens de rentrer et comme plusieurs fois
avant de partir depuis depuis quelques
temps maintenant
avant de partir 26 temps je suis partagé
entre deux émotions
la peur la peur d'imaginer qu'avec tout
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
peut-être dangereux pour moi de partir
tout seul baloutchistan dans cette jeu
dans cette zone rouge
une peur alimenté par des médias
anxiogène omniprésent
maintenant je le sais nous informe
autant qu'ils nous désinforme et puis je
suis partagé évidemment avec l' envie de
voir mes amis de voir mes amis surfeur
de voir cham sa famille baloutche ma
famille baloutche maintenant alors comme
quand tout le temps quand j'ai des
doutes je veux whatsapp chance j'ai
envoyé un message au mois de mars il dit
j'ai peur sur quoi il m'a répondu et
sinon tu à autre chose à me dire alors
comme j'ai fais entièrement confiance
est entièrement confiance à sa famille
je décidé de repartir comme d'habitude
et j'ai bien fait parce que c'était
encore incroyable heureusement mon rêve
de vouloir continuer à écrire cette
histoire avec mes amis iraniens a été
plus fort que la peur et ça m'a conforté
une fois de plus que jamais je ne
laisserai aucune peur m'empêcher de
vivre mes rêves
merci